this bac the country
we have a directive services to
party in the papers face go into
training strategy regularization of
second ips distillation win32 music and
in the first party will try different
combination of regularization we do very
expensive ablation in the papers in the
most important including  a series
of silly increases but say yes to dact
rings other parameters ten thousand
possible lives you you taste of
performance with that but will kick in
your ablation all time the scene hyper
parameter therefore the reason sometimes
some combinations of method that does
and work  substance when we move is
casting is in rwanda but rising
there would be no model aux covered
but it's you try to find the learning
white stripes the way ticket maybe you
can have model that convergent
can be yes therefore do that because there
is  the other lot of great to do that we
have to do not have great search for
each of and it's not the goal of the
seas part of  is to have good by this
to start second part and they
won't all be itec exactly the scene
hyper parameter first louis tribes of
distillation beast
we have some problems of distillation
except hygiene and liuzhou destination
with her with the soft out of the
teacher beast woodstock distillation we
have not very good performance
maybe because he is the love with some
distiller chain is is a little bit far
from the classic and loss may be to have
the good stuff ten fear the very
young lotfi father parameter we don't  do
that we prefer any challenge to heart
distillation it this super saint paul of which
she is nor by amateurs of the accountant
temperature helping to valentine reicher
between the good shoes label better the
teacher you take the only the mask of
the teacher pnue this date there that the
label bad vantage of this label the
teacher will take into account
the atacama such chain own the night is
young boys high tech parts of the image
with another el  ement the [ __ ]
yes the Czech has cording to that
if our shoulder everything is known to death
of the two men was that of all
then to increase at a place the rest
we have time that the pit
and dubai increases speed
of  'raise for each images of the
repetitions of the knee made with
different date augmentation technique
which proposes a series peter and to
its not the same batch
pod mixer because originally
ayuso repeated augmentation louise suited
enormous tel isync besides my hand is
our problem  ce turkish boat climate
gameplay mutation the different
increase are in the sun beach but
good grade below saturday pilou
immediate
we want to work with transformer because
there is less ar de bay est ce
transformers armor flexible cancun est
nico there is not a re coded convolution
etc
therefore we try to work with
transform an image classification
c'est mon fric comme youtube video was
quite potter is convolution pick up when
you're expecting the tuesday patch our
methods and his nerves this weekend six
legs extraction at zhouqu evolution but
it's conversion louise notebook look size
christine strider side story sixtine
kernel of sight the sixteen strider
sixtine weekend as need you might
transforms different departments
this ballad you we learn the position
en coding like in the white paper is
possible to to use for in stone se
sinusoid force opposition force
coding so from 0.9 the zionists
panic it's scary when monaco it
's not so much to  la mode au cnt
won 5 e
yes transform you have to try to
reduce the best is it was this
stupid behavior so av ar de bay 6
lighting transform you all good volts
or learn something that is dead
flexible fight in my opinion on
the insistence with the complete
distillation in the revolution bike
inside the transformers which way you
want to transform that work little bit
likecool nationale noc network
therefor  e we cry the distillation of
the mauro brothers da dalto ita quick fix
tell me ah but yes yes the teacher
transformers improve little bit of
performance to be experienced it will
run into use with the complete
iphone 5 battery wished very big
transformer everything  distilled inside the
smaller transformer maybe this should
the work that we only the same
transformer at stitcher end equivalent of
caunes is unheard of show that are better
experimental work
may be windows distillation token
it works exactly like the class token
the last hope and in  the artificial
tokyo used to aggregates formation of
the [ __ ] is 6 12
atention and then we use only stock and
for the prediction of distillation token
has the similar compartment between the
distillery chain riu class tocane with
two worlds ends distillation token with
a little of the teachers  and we have the
de distillation token learn more about
the teacher 66 yes check the hot spots
of class token n distilla  tion token of
agreements between the teacher output
between the class token hatred distilled
shon in tokyo it's more important to win
the des stations total de dix stations
tocane hills closer to the heart of the
complete teacher not to store and
think that this can help because  we have
we apart mort similar to françois mende
compartment est allotted mort similar to
de communes est qu'on peut avoir m
she said yes to gries get to the
beginning the different things because
they are different
je classe token have to find the green
cross  the beautiful building tinto can have to
find the hot spots of the teacher
isync therefore zeller our different think in
the atention in the different parts of
transformer because the grinch au label
death and the de distiller had faults
rather than teachers arkwight different
because there is  the data augmentation
we use 4 mx 1 and mx is its strength and or
is very very strong data augmentation in
2010 yes mix of different himeji  perform
to win the label and the teachers and
fitch expects the impact of these two
figures in the case in the eyes without
distillation the
models  it dates from death nor 100 m
and nintendo a thing little girl good
idea
classification can be informed not 10
do you think that can be a gentleman
project and cry or days of installation
transform beast it possible to adapt
the method for complete boat we  don't
rise in the methods in one radio specter
it's in the fix press method we use
elsewhere resolution strength of fine tuning
because in the classical of training
procedure user brush area this
group i take the crop between ait
personne l and return of the
immediate original therefore we were trying times
higher resolution because i'm still here
you take an image of the eyes of sound
system five hundred by five hundred and
take it for this image resizer a  it
nobody everything everything everything right one
before three new recruits who for
you the resolution elsewhere higher than
at tea stein because this time is your
web in pictures
size five hundred miles island gold to be
done step cycling match ed tech center
pop the force of the breezes  discrepancy
between the training strategy and
testing strategy for you have to try to
take that and look girly show your
dreams and to be like exit time when
distillation team in fine tuning
force force 10 shots model distillates force
yd clp little bit we try  boss battle
fuyuki de distillation resounds everywhere at
the ifan dring dring
this era with the smaller is so fear
escort traditions and turn me
into a lady
fancy for you mean you might have just
imagined it is necessary to imagine that a louis
d'or hinault from scratch
so strong we have some good results a
sense yes the running from scratch en cif
art and with kinect teacher training and
start and rich
nineteen  ve in too bad in six parts because
the reason to paint transformer to ruiz
sensitive to hard hook optimization
but because we don't have fine le guen
all the good training here pitou drags
transformers 3 which was suitable late march 8th
stable les africans try to  try it
your way back performance
maybe it's not due to the greek of data
beast
it can be you too bad they lose
parameter started to have good concludes
young yes transformer may be your area
is good accountant type is an
important parameter to try to value debt
after john dataset or other revelations
date at this moment weezer then imagine
is a model yes you are worth paul thompson
imagine life all the image of the label to
see if we were if you imagine because
when you try to adapt e learning and etc
you can offer feet  high single sing
carrying everything is there
thank you like they need of what kind of
in the wind systems tanit effect on may 10
because 3:26 p.m. transformers can't
lurn a period where he is positioning himself  au
coding callum in various any
translation rotation and its certified fans look
in the city paper series and look the
similarity between the different vector
of the position coding nuken cseries one
positioning coding will be more cruel to
ty with its neighbor the yukon cseries
some kind  of translation lindbergh in
rotation a variant
we may be what if you don't have a lot
of data made it may be the size of the
transformers regularization traille
trinh duc you're stupid at issy it possible
to have good performance build your data
that may  be very few data transformant
but big and hold on to work but i'll be
there is also this problem swiss com net
and picard feeling and thank you lie to
me because the transformers is very
flexible with the data augmentation
you will teach the transformers  to learn
are a strong period instanz isync
eyeka news death date argument yes
this transformers in cornettes franson
swiss mike brant daiichi configuration
added ms  klein de cornette with this
date augmentation ou l avou bad
performance
because they think it's too strong
imagined sums forms off net from 10 a.m. to
12 p.m.
google health in there is it it's good
idea to try below man sumnt
feature of to know at  different
level of of transformer must be signed
it's hard to you find to find matching
between the two architecture eco 60 of
future joystick by our
similar to whole building transforming
nicosie find that in the transformers
you don't have done downswing upholstery
atention network in  chains size fits
any fine correspondence between the
dark and readings your make it possible
to continue to construction things done
and in one group b extreme
in fine of mount of love and features
youtube growth
an isync verification caunette
architecture that are very different
do a session  shows net loss
et cetera we learn to classify may be
different clint eastwood or henson
bling think it's b  etter you young man
seems with architecture resonates
touag overall louise its marks and
readings because there is more diversity
in the prodigy maybe the event of future
all classified infinite butt
different architectures channel of their
different way you do you think there
there is for example  in your step beyond
in somalia where different we
don't do many little things
of distillation and therefore of the future baby
like of facebook like an eau du jury
indies their company
with a look like to win it is a lot of
freedom and facebook queen  we will work
likinga can be collapse france go
work with my my facebook advisor like
work with my academic at 12h university
on youtube
annie fraudsters at yannick monnet and
product du fils de reiser producers at
new river city yes they can be
useful author il  we don't have to see that we are
really queen we don't have we don't have
to apply to work for production we have
eyes to see that academic quinine li  ve
is long and this pitch of the problems
muse the dates terrorist date the actor
mines off of time the people need to
complete a pitch that is in france where
he wants
the program all of the trap of an
isis company national programs
fridge to completely transform
transformed this gift store like in
rotten iowa what we came to animate
reclassification does not transform into a
battle where we were attacking work
finally on the assets that transformers m6
will transform us from aulnoye what i wore
maybe i'm with commas technique
darcos yorkton like johnny  wright
[Music]
texting to transform our match after
reading on the ground for example 80 go and
transformed into a book the game and so
that's my queen a second round between
two ends and mitch talk and then you
have sequel to the future text open text to
your freedom  transforming the cros word of
presentation of experiences in
many films
problem it is only at the tip of the finger
saturday frank rich wilson and therefore our
services of p  problem having different the
watch different methods token
between texts and images
good idea inna modja here like inpex
peso 0 some problems with very old and
they can't find that if you try to
united with the lui
hyde resolution imaging news
coming long sequence and  the attention to
two logics at the city
complex therefore you have for you will have some
problems with the memory and the speed
of the models things with some people
can fly to the witch and the complexity
of the new beaters performance is
unpublished
bud racing in may be  some technique
sums nlp technics can be used for
images transformed
something like for what is your email is
for use in one hundred
netqin is an acquired six matches of guns
and class google had drawn itself like
you and i
[Music]
of the future the  author weekend where the
author demonstrates a spartan force to
transform in this sense
the result of hybrid architecture with
cornette extract future transform everything
to work  in this picture in disguise of
futures are not not because they make the
better future shape like net she
things with a lot of thing to do with
the beach x trail sean may be better to
you did architectural like no use
different perspectives at otu extract
information  in the bee gees how to
die all extract information in the
days and ride with the lost thing i
think it's french touch wiz transformer
we have to find the beast architecture
tout tout tout xtrac informations
wikango doucet nos machines
just do it take you think we'  re mobile
flagship to have optimal
training solutions france's match in optimal
babys mini you but well to harkis